the second season of war zone 2 and
Modern Warfare 2's multiplayer was
projected to go live on or around
February 1st these projections were
based off of the days left on the season
one battle pass however known Call of
Duty data Miner Cod sploits suggested
season 2 was gearing up for a delay Well
turns out cod's blades was right and
Activision has officially confirmed that
season 2 will Now launch on February
15th the date lined up right where Cod
sploits predicted it would be based on
data mining that showed that the last
season one bundle will arrive on
February 2nd with the end date of
February 15. as part of the announcement
Activision said the team has been making
several changes based on what they heard
from the player community coincidentally
a nearly identical situation affected
last year's Vanguard and Warzone 1
season 2 update which was delayed from
February 1st to February 14th to give
the developers two more weeks to work on
stability bug fixes and game
optimizations the new update will
include a variety of content for Warzone
2 and Modern Warfare 2 including
Resurgence and a new small map for
Warzone 2 ranked play and new maps modes
and weapons for Modern Warfare 2.
further specifics were not shared and
when you need a break from Call of Duty
season 2 next month you can stretch your
virtual trigger fingers with atomic
heart which releases just shy of a week
later on February 21st recently the
game's developer mudfish took to Twitter
to answer a Fan's question about console
performance and revealed atomic heart
will prioritize frame rate over
resolution when it needs to mun fish
said quote solid 60fps 4K in Dungeons
and dynamic resolution mostly 4K at
60fps in open world next gen of course
aside from this information not much has
been revealed about atomic heart on
consoles as the trailers have consisted
of PC footage there has been no word of
giving players the choice between
quality in performance like we've come
to expect from current Jam games and
last gem performance is also unknown at
the time of this recording and now let's
talk about a different kind of
first-person shooter today developer
future lab announced the Tomb Raider
special pack for power wash simulator
available starting January 31st this
free that's right free DLC will have you
cleaning the iconic Croft manner
according to the FAQ section of the
announcement this DLC will be a mini
campaign with a short story and five new
levels to enjoy there are even more
changes coming to power wash Sim but the
devs said they'll release more info on
that when the update launches have you
tried out power watch Sim I love the
game so if you haven't I highly
recommend you check it out and also
check out Fall Out Boy's new single I
know this isn't gaming related but like
I just really love the song it reminds
me of old Fallout Boy old old Fallout
Boy not the last three albums if you
know you know old Fallout Boy I'll see
you tomorrow